alright five days after everyone else
uploaded their review for this movie
Here I am thank you for your patience it
shows me you care right in there
Deadpool so Deadpool stars Ryan Reynolds
us the Merc with the mouth he's done it
before didn't work out for anybody so in
a world of re-rolling the Dyson give it
a solid Mulligan Ryan Reynolds is for
the first time proper Deadpool the
production of this was just really
interesting that test footage came out a
couple years ago at Comic Con and the
bunch of fans got together and oh hey
this is awesome people make youtube
videos about it I made a YouTube video
about it I was like that's perfect just
do that make that Deadpool I think we'll
have a solid Deadpool movie and they did
and they delivered the greatest apology
for that monstrosity they could have
ever delivered good job Fox good on you
it's moving this fantastic first of all
Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool is great we
knew he was a great pick for Deadpool
were just like this you know don't sew
his mouth shut like a [ __ ] idiot
because Ryan Reynolds is a great [ __ ]
talker and Deadpool needs to be a great
[ __ ] talker only that the humor was
great the opening credits in this movie
I've never seen more perfect opening
credits than the opening credits in
Deadpool I knew what I was in for at
that point I was like yes yes NWA humor
is really hard to pin it's almost a
spoof but it's not a spoof it's very
meta and I wanted that Deadpool needs to
have meta humor but it's not cheesy it's
not toilet humor it's Deadpool humor not
only that but the action was exciting to
this movie starts out with an action
sequence that is ultimately that test
footage we saw a couple years ago it's
the opening action sequence in this
movie and it's rough it's raw this movie
is rated R and it's not only like kind
of rated R with the lagoons turn rated
up we don't want to be too heavy on it
because it's still a Marvel property and
we got to be PC about it so we'll have
them say a couple of f-bombs maybe a
couple of bloody parts maybe no the [ __ ]
goes down and it is real it is violent
and it's exciting it's not just chop
chop here and shoot shoot there no it's
super clever this is scene where he
decapitated dude and then kicks his head
like a soccer ball into another guy
raise your hand if you wanted to see
that in a Deadpool movie I know you're
out there you're come on who's with me
I'm putting Colossus in this movie with
Deadpool is great - I wanted to see now
that Colossus is there you want to see
more x-men characters you're like
okay sequels but it's so great because
they're so polar opposite Colossus is a
good dude and Wade Wilson is kind of an
[ __ ] lovable [ __ ] but the dude is
Merc with the mouth it's not really hero
material
same with negasonic teenage warhead
brianna hildebrand is that hey I'm
terrible with names so I'm probably
mispronouncing it but I thought she was
great because she added four teenaged
angst humor but it didn't end at the
teenage angst team or when time came for
her to throw down and be a badass she
was actually a badass guys go out there
and see Deadpool right now making this
quick summing it up for you Deadpool is
the funniest comedy I've seen in a very
long time and it's the most fun I have
had in an action movie in a while no
YouTube commenters not a slam for Star
Wars I love Star Wars to have fun with
it I'm just saying it's hard for a movie
like this to find the balance Deadpool
completely found its balance it's funny
it's action-packed I love the way they
show you his story he's Deadpool then it
goes back and shows us a little of the
past and there's more Deadpool than goes
back and shows you a little more of the
past if it was just a chronological
movie he'd be a little more I'd be like
it's a little boring in the first half
of it since they space it out nope cool
movie all around this is redemption of
the Deadpool name if ever there was one
by Fox itself I had fun with this movie
I love this movie I had a grin for 90%
of it and Deadpool is awesome tacular
perfect Valentine's Day movie in fact if
your girlfriend suggests I really want
to watch Deadpool you slap a ring on you
slap it on right now right so Deadpool
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more